[Musique]
n'hésitez de début à moi aussi je suis
heureux de voir j'ai mis toutes ses
affaires sur lui d'abord qu'est-ce que
ça non l'équité et tu sais la souveraine
revient
voulait pas studio et du papier
[Musique]
il est tellement simple
tu vas en ligne de votre main il est
très fatigué oui ça m'a même nom à votre
tête ah bah je vous dérange pas trop
jalouse ou moins
mais vous avez trouvé ça bien que vous
écriviez des jeux non mais je sais pas
ça me sort de partout bien plus qu'une m
pourquoi je voudrais savoir le sud ça
donne envie
une femme de troisième en face quand on
vous lit on la voit
sa forme on sait quand
[Musique]
début je l'aimé comme un fou alors sa
peau on dit ça sans faire georges des
têtes à couper ce délit quand je peux
pas
[Musique]
beaucoup vous décrochez pas c'est quoi
ça sert à rien une porte ou presque qui
travaillent tous à ces packs à cause
d'elles est vrai que un peu jeune pour
vous savez qu est ce que ça veut dire
elle est un peu jeune
[Musique]
problème
excusez moi je me sens pas très bien
peut-être car dit il
[Musique]
outre les lui donner je crois qu'il faut
pas
m